merci Philippa de nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure élu de
la Manche membre du groupe les
républicains on va parler de la
politique migratoire assez longuement
tout à l'heure mais d'abord dans
l'actualité c'est évidemment cette
victoire des Bleus hier les Bleus qui
sont donc en finale pas de gros
débordements finalement hier lors des
célébrations alors que un gros
dispositif de sécurité avait mis avait
été mis en place en prévention il y a eu
un peu plus de 100 interpellations à
Paris est-ce que ça veut dire que le
dispositif de sécurité était bien géré
d'abord ça veut dire qu'il y a un bon
esprit sportif entre les supporteurs des
deux équipes à l'image d'ailleurs du
comportement des deux équipes sur sur le
terrain hier soir et évidemment un très
beau match qui nous a vraiment réjouis
et qui nous donne beaucoup d'espoir pour
une victoire en finale
l'ordre public
c'est beaucoup de prévention et de
dissuasion
tout le monde avait peur et pour hier
soir faut dire la vérité tout le monde
avait peur
et finalement tout s'est bien passé
grâce au fait que le dispositif
préventif a été à la hauteur fait que on
est arrêté avant qu'il rejoignent les
Champs-Elysées un certain nombre
d'individus qui ne sont pas des
supporteurs pas non plus des Marocains
ou des Français mais des voyous tout
simplement les avoir arrêtés alors
qu'ils étaient munis de dispositifs
qui s'apparente à des armes ou d'armes
ça c'est une preuve de l'efficacité de
nos dispositif de sécurité mais donc le
ministère de l'intérieur ce qui était
important c'est que ces dispositifs
soient connus à l'avance et qu'il soit
effectivement bien opérationnel et oui
nos forces de sécurité une fois de plus
ont été à la hauteur et c'est important
de le souligner et de les remercier
l'autre a une autre actualité ce sont
ces perquisitions qui ont été menées
mardi on l'a appris hier le siège du
cabinet de conseil McKinsey et au siège
du parti présidentiel Renaissance dans
le cadre des interventions des cabinets
de conseils notamment dans les campagnes
électorales d'Emmanuel Macron il y a des
enquêtes en cours qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de ces perquisitions la justice
fait son travail il faut pas s'en
étonner c'est le Sénat qui a mis en
évidence les abus
auxquelles du côté de l'État on a
procédé en pensant que c'est une erreur
complète que c'est les méthodes de
l'entreprise qui vont permettre de
moderniser l'État mais la nature même de
l'action publique est différente du
travail de l'entreprise c'est pas du
marketing c'est pas du commerce c'est
pas une usine de production
l'état un rôle de régulation ne peut pas
transposer les méthodes du privé au
public sans une profonde adaptation la
réforme de la haute fonction publique
est aussi une hérésie et il était temps
de donner un coup d'arrêt à cette
et de recentrer l'État sur l'exercice de
son autorité qui doit se faire avec
l'instrument d'une haute fonction
publique et d'une fonction publique
dédiée aux services publics et non pas
avec des amateurs
un grand cabinet de conseils aux
entreprises n'est pas qualifié pour
conseiller l'État pour des aspects qui
sont des aspects de politique publique
Bruno Le Maire dit alors il reconnaît un
qui a eu des abus dans le passé mais il
dit que désormais tout ça est corrigé
vous y croyez et puis nous allons le
vérifier c'est notre travail c'est notre
service après-vente demande la
commission d'enquête a fait un travail
remarquable je crois qu'il faut il faut
le saluer et dire que ça c'est le rôle
du Sénat libre indépendant non alignés
et qui donc remplit sa mission
constitutionnelle aussi importante que
la mission législative qui consiste à
être à contre-pouvoir et à aller
regarder comment se déroule l'action
publique pour la contrôler c'est le
contrôle constitutionnel par le
Parlement et en particulier par le Sénat
de l'action des pouvoirs publics le
tractualité on a vu dans le journal ce
sont ces consultations menées par
Elisabeth borde sur la réforme des
retraites elle reçoit les présidents de
groupes parlementaires les sénateurs les
républicains votent depuis des années un
report de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite il y a un sondage au doxa pour
les chaînes parlementaires puis la
presse régionale publiée ce matin qui
dit que 66% des sympathisants les
républicains approuvent cette réforme et
donc un recul de l'âge de départ est-ce
que les républicains ont d'autres choix
de voté cette réforme mais nous ne
connaissons pas la réforme le
gouvernement ne cesse de la reculer ça
fait plus de 5 ans qu'il recule au pied
du mur il tergiverses il est grand temps
qu'il sorte du bois et à ce moment-là
nous serons quoi commenter mais nous
avons nous-mêmes notre position notre
doctrine et elle est fixée dans les
votes du Sénat en effet depuis de
nombreuses années
augmentation de la durée de cotisation
en ayant en allant plus vite dans cette
augmentation qui se fait tous les trois
ans en ce moment que ce qui a été prévu
à l'époque de François Hollande et qui
était une une réforme robinet d'eau
tiède et puis augmentation de l'âge de
la retraite non pas pour rejoindre les
pays européens qui sont à 67 ans mais
pour aller au moins à 64 ans quelques
années et puis dans quelques années on
fera le bilan la réforme des retraites
ne se fait pas en un jour mais elle est
nécessaire elle est nécessaire d'abord
pour les petits retraités avec tous les
correctifs nécessaires pour ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler très tôt avec des
faibles qualifications et aussi pour
ceux qui ont eu un travail
particulièrement
usant c'est ce qu'on appelle la
pénibilité
tout le monde sait ce qu'il faut faire
mais juste pour être clair ça veut dire
que vous 65 ans saignette ça va trop
loin c'est 64 ans le bon âge mais nous
avons l'idée d'une démarche équilibrée
et dans un premier temps ce qui est déjà
beaucoup pour les Français passons
64 ans et là aussi avec une
progressivité c'est pas demain pour ceux
qui s'apprêtent à prendre leur retraite
ils vont pas brusquement prendre deux
ans dans la vue les gens s'inquiètent de
ça il faut quand même expliquer les
choses mais il faut surtout leur dire
c'est votre retraite qu'on veut sauver
c'est pas du tout pour vous diminuer vos
droits c'est au contraire pour vous les
maintenir alors qu'il y a moins de
cotisants qui payent pour les retraites
et plus de retraités qui vivent
heureusement pour eux plus longtemps en
cas d'utilisation du 49-3 puisque c'est
possible puisque le gouvernement va
passer par un texte budgétaire certains
députés à l’air n'écarte pas le fait de
déposer une motion de censure est-ce que
vous approuveriez cet acte mais je fais
pas de politique fiction j'attends de
voir le texte du Gouvernement je
souhaite beaucoup que ce texte soit là
hauteur des attentes et jusqu'à présent
j'ai des doutes là-dessus parce que ça a
beaucoup traîné en fait on a perdu un
quinquennat n'en perdons pas un second
et il faut il faut absolument aboutir je
crois que vraiment il y a un moment où
nous ne pouvons pas nous faire la
politique du pire nous ne pouvons pas
attendre 50 plus pour réformer les
retraites nous voulons qu'une réforme
qui soit suffisamment ambitieuse puisse
passer parce que cette ambition est au
service des Français en parler de la
politique migratoire maintenant chez les
bas et les abeilles bordent à présenter
les grandes lignes de son projet de loi
immigration c'était mardi devant les
sénateurs mais cette politique elle se
mène aussi à l'échelle de l'Union
européenne et on va parler de tout ça
avec Steve Jourdain
[Musique]
est aujourd'hui décrié son avenir est au
coeur des attentions puisqu’un nouveau
directeur doit bientôt être désigné
alors avant d'en parler rappelez-nous
Frontex qu'est-ce que c'est peut-être
l'agence européenne la plus puissante en
matière de prérogative de puissance
publique ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
qu'elle a été créée en 2004 pour
surveiller les frontières extérieures de
l'espace Schengen les 26 États européens
qui composent cet espace sont
responsables de la surveillance de leur
propre frontières mais frontext à
plusieurs pouvoirs elle peut intervenir
en soutien à un État membre en déployant
des équipes sur le terrain par voie de
maire de terre ou encore par voie
aérienne elle peut aussi aider des pays
tiers à juguler les flux migratoires
irréguliers vers l'Europe pour faire
tout ça l'agence dispose d'un effectif
de 1900 personnes d'ici 2027 on devrait
même atteindre le chiffre de 10000
égards de côtes et garde frontières
organes et c'est aujourd'hui une agence
que le Sénat considère comme étant en
crise oui paradoxe de cette crise la
démission en avril dernier sont
directeurs Fabrice les guéri une
démission a provoquée par des
révélations sur le refoulement illégal
de migrants en mer Égée je vous donne un
exemple de pratique pointée du doigt des
migrants à Coste sur le territoire
européen via les côtes grecques mais ils
sont ensuite renvoyés en mer par les
gardes frontières c'est ce qu'on appelle
un push back un renvoi en bon français
c'est une procédure illégale car elle
est contraire au droit international et
l'ancien directeur de Frontex est accusé
d'avoir eu connaissance de ces pratiques
et même de les avoir encouragé en
conséquence il a été conduit à la
démission au printemps dernier regard et
la commission des affaires européennes
du Sénat adopté une proposition de
résolution pour interpeller le
gouvernement oui les sénateurs demandent
plusieurs choses ils souhaitent une
accélération de la procédure de
désignation du futur directeur la mise
en place d'un groupe de contrôle
parlementaire ou encore la clarification
des missions de l'agence Frontex
Philippe Bas parmi ces missions est-ce
que vous considérez que au respect des
droits fondamentaux ça doit faire partie
des prérogatives de l'agence et enfin il
ne faut pas que le fait de veiller au
respect de la loi qui s'impose à tous
aboutissent à une forme de paralysie
d'un organisme qui depuis maintenant le
mois d'avril n'a plus de directeur
avec l'importance de cette enjeu du
contrôle des frontières européennes
parce que si vous n'avez pas un bon
contrôle des frontières européennes ça
n'est pas au niveau des frontières
nationales que vous allez récupérer les
difficultés liées à la pression
migratoire donc il faut que cet
organisme est très rapidement son
directeur
frontext agit évidemment dans le cadre
des règles qui sont applicables mais il
ne faut pas tirer prétexte de
difficultés d'application de ces règles
pour paralyser un organisme aussi
important et c'est ce qu'a voulu faire
notre commission des affaires
européennes et notre commission des lois
avec ce projet de résolution signale à
la fois du président de la commission
des affaires européennes monsieur Rapin
et du président de la commission des
lois Monsieur François Noël buffet c'est
une alerte que nous lançons nous sommes
dans une situation d'urgence je vais
vous donner quelques chiffres des
chiffres de de Frontex sur le
franchissement irrégulier des frontières
de l'Union européenne par des migrants
ce chiffre atteint le nombre de 281
cette année c'est une augmentation de
77% par rapport à la même période en
2021 font accès dépassés aujourd'hui
pas tout seul son texte vous l'avez
expliqué très justement via en appui des
États mais quand
résultat qui a de faible moyen pour
contrôler ses frontières doit les
contrôler tout seul il n'y arrive pas et
c'est la raison pour laquelle il y a de
l'intérêt de l'Europe et de chacun des
grands pays de l'Europe comme la France
qui sont des pays qui attirent encore
trop d'étrangers clandestins d'avoir cet
outil et cet outil soit en état de
fonctionnement je n'arrive pas à
comprendre comment on peut accepter que
depuis le mois d'avril cette organisme
n'est pas de directeur il faut réformer
cet agence selon vous il faut surtout
lui donner davantage de moyens et là
aussi vous l'avez indiqué les États
membres ont pris des décisions à cet
égard pour renforcer les moyens de
Frontex et c'est et c'est vital dans son
discours au Parlement de sur la
politique migratoire parce qu'elle a
parlé au député la semaine dernière et
elle a parlé au sénateur cette semaine
Elisabeth borne elle a dit qu'il fallait
renforcer les moyens de contexte elle a
dit c'est aussi à l'échelle européenne
que nous lutterons plus efficacement
contre les réseaux de passeurs et dans
ce texte Gérald Darmanin propose que
dans la loi soit adoptée des
dispositions pour porter jusqu'à 20 le
crime de passeur qui aujourd'hui est en
délit ça vous paraît être bien écoutez
vous voyez bien que c'est pasteur ce
sont les négriers des temps modernes
c'est une honte pour l'Europe de ne pas
être plus efficace dans la lutte contre
cette exploitation quand vous vous
rendez compte que on met sur l'eau des
bateaux avec une réserve d'essence qui
fait que le bateau s'arrête au milieu de
la Méditerranée pour que ensuite les
migrants soient menacés de mort et que
c'est ONG se précipitent pour les
secourir et que ainsi la pression
s'exerce sous la menace de la noyade
on ne peut qu'être scandalisé de la
situation actuelle et donc oui tout ce
qu'on pourra faire pour réprimer plus
efficacement les passeurs et leurs
complices c'est quelque chose de
d'indispensable mais vous le dites ce
sont les ONG qui vont chercher ces
bateaux est-ce que c'est affrontex d'y
aller est-ce qu'il faut le mettre en
place un système pour que ce soit
Frontex qui gère ses bateaux de migrants
dans les Méditerranée il faut surtout
faire en sorte que
au point de départ de ces bateaux ont
réussi à exercer une pression sur des
États qui sont également des états
complices c'est souvent en pleine
délices pour ne pas laisser partir ces
bateaux vous avez auditionné hier Didier
l'allemand le nouveau secrétaire général
de la mer comment ça s'est passé
et bien comme toutes les auditions à la
commission des lois ça s'est passé d'une
manière très rigoureuse et méticuleuse
et préfets l'allemand aujourd'hui
secrétaire à la mer n'a pas caché la
préoccupation que les pouvoirs publics
ont légitimement à l'égard de cette
forme de complicité objective dans toute
cette chaîne du de la traversée de la
Méditerranée entre les États en pleine
déliquescence qui ne contrôle pas leur
plage les passeurs qui laissent au
milieu de la Méditerranée les voyageurs
les organisations non gouvernementales
qui les récupère et ensuite les étapes
qui ne savent pas quoi en faire il y a
là une difficulté qui montre bien qu'il
n'y a pas de solution à la question
migratoire sans qu'elle passe par des
accords internationaux et des accords
d'État état avec aussi des pressions qui
doivent s'ex sur les pays d'origine
merci Steve à tout à l'heure on parlera
de foot tout à l'heure ce sera assise
dans le club et nous on va continuer à
parler de la politique migratoire parce
que c'est aussi l'actualité dans votre
département de la Manche au moins quatre
personnes ont trouvé la mort hier dans
une opération de sauvetage pour en
parler on va retrouver David elmode
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
journaliste à Tendance Ouest et vous
allez nous parler de la question des
migrants avec notamment les tentatives
d'intrusion dans la zone portuaire
bonjour à tous effectivement début de
semaine les équipes de danse Ouest se
sont intéressés aux tentatives
d'intrusion ils ont notamment rencontré
l'association d'aide aux migrants
itinérance et donc cette association
vient en aide à une soixantaine de
personnes qui sont installées dans un
camp à Cherbourg et la majorité d'entre
elles est afghane et sa population tente
de monter dans les camions pour
rejoindre une meilleure vie vers
l'Angleterre du style l'association veut
s'opposer aux travaux actuels de
renforcement des clôtures au niveau de
la gare maritime de Cherbourg à savoir
le terminal transmanche et des clôtures
de 4 mètres 2 mètres 80 initialement sur
les 3,5 km qui protège la zone d'accès
restreint donc sont donc en cours
d'installation et comme quel est et
dans le Calvados Cherbourg est aussi
concerné avec des intrusions en hausse
selon les derniers chiffres on annonce
près de 1000 intrusions de migrants sur
Cherbourg dans la zone d'accès restreint
en octobre 2022 pour une moyenne
mensuelle de 760 environ alors la
donesse l'association dénonce n un mur
érigé en pleine ville et des blessures
graves suite à ces travaux avec je cite
des membres cassés les mains et les
visages lacérer et de leur côté les
services de l'État précisent que ces
travaux sont destinés à renforcer la
sécurité du port et ainsi à améliorer la
lutte contre ces tentatives alors
monsieur va et c'est vous êtes vous qui
êtes sénateur faut-il plus de dissuasion
si vous laissez des voix de passage aux
migrants clandestins vers l'Angleterre
grande ouverte vous allez attirer
énormément de clandestins et c'est toute
la difficulté de l'exercice de cette
autorité nécessaire
de l'État que de se trouver confronté à
la nécessité
d'empêcher le passage avec le risque que
cela comporte pour des migrants qui
veulent tellement passer qu'ils vont
prendre des risques pour leur propre vie
on le disait tout à l'heure pour ce qui
concerne la traversée de la mer au fond
les migrants s'exposent à la noyade
parce que cette
exposition et pour eux un moyen de
rejoindre l'Angleterre sur les bateaux
de sauvetage de la même façon les
migrants vont s'exposer à des risques
considérables en essayant de franchir
les barrages qu'on érige pour empêcher
le départ de notre territoire mais nous
ne pouvons pas à la fois nous plaindre
que de l'autre côté de la Méditerranée
on laisse partir les clandestins vers
l'Europe et refuser nous-mêmes quand
nous sommes face à nos responsabilités
de mettre en oeuvre
des obstacles matériels et des obstacles
humains pour ne pas attirer des migrants
en nombre supérieurs vous avez cité des
chiffres qui sont déjà considérables et
bien il faut que des messages simples
soient émis dans le monde que la France
n'est pas une passoire à migrants et que
par conséquent on fait très attention
ceci est difficile ceci est difficile
même à assumer mais il faut le faire
est-ce que la coopération avec le
Royaume-Uni est suffisante il y a un
accord qui a été signé la mi-novembre
entre Paris et Londres avec une
enveloppe financière de la part du
Royaume-Uni pour que il y ait plus de
policiers et de gendarmes sur les plages
françaises est-ce que c'est suffisant
pour vous nous ne pouvons pas être de
simples sous-traitant du Royaume-Uni
et il faut faire attention à ce que le
Royaume-Uni donne ses propres moyens
pour
permettre de filtrer en quelque sorte
des demandes dont certaines peuvent tout
de même mettre légitimes et admises par
le Royaume-Uni
je considère que nous avons maintenant
un nouvel accord il faut lui laisser sa
chance il faut naturellement même si le
brexit ne facilite pas les choses que la
coopération franco-britannique ne cesse
s'améliorer de s'adapter à l'évolution
des situations mais là en ce moment on
voit apparaître de nouveaux abcès de
fixation et c'est les abcès de fixation
doivent être traités par des mesures de
dissuasion du type de celles qui sont
mises en oeuvre à Cherbourg on va
remercier David elmode qui était
justement avec nous depuis Cherbourg
merci beaucoup journaliste à Tendance
Ouest merci d'avoir été avec nous on
termine en parlant de votre partie les
républicains qui ont donc un nouveau
président et erikiotti est-ce que vous
êtes inquiet pour l'unité pour l'avenir
de votre partie en vérité il n'y a pas
de mystère j'ai voté Bruno Retailleau
pourquoi parce que Bruno Retailleau a
une capacité de rassemblement que j'ai
pu vérifier depuis des années au Sénat
ou toutes les sensibilités sont
accueillies au sein de notre groupe
c'est pour moi le bon modèle je ne veux
pas d'une dérive qui conduirait LR à
devenir une sorte de force supplétive
pour d'autres formations politiques
certaines d'entre elles comme le
rassemblement national représente
incompatible avec nos valeurs j'attends
de la nouvelle équipe qu'elle fasse la
démonstration de sa capacité de
maintenir l'indépendance de notre
formation et sa qualité de grande
formation de gouvernement nous sommes un
parti de gouvernement nous ne pouvons
pas dire n'importe quoi sur n'importe
quel sujet nous devons prouver notre
esprit de responsabilité cette qualité
là que les Français recherchent dans
l'intérêt général vous avez des doutes
sur l'étanchéité entre le rassemblement
national et les LR avec Éric ciottier à
cette atterrissiotique qui ont le
rappelle à a dit pendant la
présidentielle qu'il préférait Éric
Zemmour et Emmanuel Macron ça vous
inquiète il appartient à Éric Ciotti de
lever ses doutes s'il veut être
rassembleur de sa famille politique pour
ce qui me concerne j'ouvre une période
d'observation et je suis très vigilant
moi je suis disciple
de Jacques Chirac de Simone Veil il y a
des choses que je ne peux pas accepter
quand Jacques Chirac fonde l'UMP devenu
LR c'est après sa victoire contre
Jean-Marie Le Pen en rassemblant toutes
les sensibilités de la droite et du
centre les libéraux les radicaux les UDF
les RP avec cette idée que nous sommes
une grande force de gouvernement à la
fois européenne à la fois sociale à la
fois libérale et ferme sur le régalien
mais également ouverte sur le social et
pas recroqueviller sur elle-même pas
enclavé dans un segment de l'opinion
publique qui ne cesse de se rétrécir et
bien pensons à cette histoire qui a été
une très belle histoire et construisons
l'avenir en cohérence avec ce que nous
sommes depuis la fondation de ce parti
pas Éric zuti lui dit que les
républicains doivent être en partie de
droite affirmée il est à droite droite
est-ce que ça vous inquiète sur le fait
que vous soyez encore ce parti de la
droite et du centre je n'ai aucune
objection à ce que cette droite incarnée
par scioti soit une des sensibilités de
notre formation politique mais
nous ne pouvons pas nous réduire à cela
sinon nous deviendrons une force
anecdotique dans la vie politique
française et je mets en garde contre ça
c'est le risque aujourd'hui c'est la
survie de votre partie qui se joue
de notre partie se joue depuis un
certain nombre d'années nous sommes
conscients que les résultats que nous
avons obtenus à la dernière élection
présidentielle montre une
marginalisation et c'est pour ça que
quand je parle de force supplétive je
n'invente pas moi ce que je souhaite
pour notre pays
c'est une force d'opposition face à un
pouvoir qui depuis cinq ans à montrer
qu'il avait abandonné toute ambition de
réforme pour notre pays déficit qui se
multiplie réforme des retraites qui ne
sont pas faites politique de
l'immigration qui n'est pas suffisamment
ferme
nucléaire pour lequel on a dit tout est
son contraire et il faut donc créer une
alternative possible qui ne soit pas une
alternative extrémiste à cette politique
qui n'en est pas une un dernier mot
Philippe parce que le score finalement
était assez serré entre une Retailleau
est-ce que ça pose aussi la question de
la candidature de Laurent Wauquiez
est-ce que pour vous il est évident que
ça doit être lui votre candidat en 2027
et qu'il faut le désigner dès maintenant
comme le souhaite Eric ciotier enfin il
faut pas mettre la charrue avant les
bœufs nous aurons bien sûr je l'espère
un candidate qui sera capable de
l'emporter à l'élection présidentielle
de 2027 mais c'est absolument
surréaliste de se projeter vers cette
élection présidentielle alors qu'il y a
plus de 4 années qui nous séparent de
cet échéance et que ces quatre années
doivent être utiles pour notre pays et
c'est tout le rôle que nous voulons
donner d'ailleurs au Sénat qui
aujourd'hui a un rôle clé pour permettre
aux réformes de se on a bien compris sur
le calendrier il faut attendre sur le
nom est-ce que Laurent est-ce que
Laurent Wauquiez c'est une évidence pour
vous mais c'est une évidence que c'est
un candidat possible mais pas le
candidat mais laissons sa chance à
l'expression de toutes les sensibilités
pendant cette première demi-heure dans
20 minutes dans le club d'État on
reviendra sur ce match France - Maroc la
qualification des Bleus célébrée dans
tout le pays et son viendra sur la
présence d'Emmanuel Macron Qatar on sera
avec deux sénateurs fans de foot Bruno
Belin que vous connaissez bien qui est
dans votre groupe et Rachid timal mais
d'abord on va cueillir notre prochaine
invité chez Mathilde de panneau qui nous
rejoint